Speaker 1: Things just continue to get worse
and worse and worse for Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Green, who now in a resurfaced
video resurfaced by Punchbowl News's Jake
Sherman, publicly stated that she would oppose
the removal of Hitler statues, hypothetical
ones, of course, so that she could tell her
children the importance of Hitler.
Historically, my guess is that there are tons
of videos of Marjorie Taylor Greene saying
ridiculous and depraved and horrible things
that will be uncovered in the future.
Remember that just in the last few weeks,
videos of Marjorie Taylor Green have resurfaced
in which she shows up to the office of Alexandria
Cacio Cortez and yells things through the
mail slot in Aoki's door at her earlier this
week, a video of Marjorie Taylor Greene comparing
wearing a mask on the House floor.
To the gassing of Jews in the Holocaust was
uncovered back in March, March, Marjorie Taylor
Green Ally, what was that guy's name?
I forget the guy's name.
An ally of Marjorie Taylor Green was caught
on video at the January 6th Trump rise.
I don't think this is going to stop.
Here's the latest video.
Marjorie Taylor Green showed up at a Dalton
Dalton, Georgia, City Council meeting in June
of twenty twenty.
This was last year after Greene finished first
in the Republican primary, but before the
general election, which made her a congresswoman
and she showed up and she specifically said
she would fight against the removal of Hitler
statues.
Check this out.
Apparently, the context in general is that
she's against removing any statues of civil
war figures or whoever else by liberals, naturally.
And she says she would even be opposed to
removing statues of Hitler.
Speaker 2: And for you all going into a runoff
and voting for me, I also want to say something
else.
I think that this is a time where our nation
is being divided and we shouldn't be we should
be brought together because this is the greatest
country in the world.
And we, like the other man, was saying about
bread crumbs, I don't think we should be fighting
about bread crumbs.
I think we should be working to come together
and work further to keep things good and keep
peace.
We're seeing situations where Christopher
Columbus, George Washington, Abraham Lincoln,
all kinds of statues are being attacked.
And it seems to be just a an effort to take
down history.
And whether I see a statue, that may be something
that I would fully disagree with, like Adolf
Hitler, maybe a statue of Satan himself, I
would not want to say take it down.
But again, it's so that I could tell my children
and teach others about who these people are,
what they did and what they may be about.
So as a congressional candidate, I just wanted
to come forward and make a statement and thank
you all for hearing everyone in your community
and also let voters know where I stand on
the matter because I'm looking to work for
everyone here.
And I felt like it was important for you to
hear me.
So thank you very much.
Speaker 1: Even a statue of Adolf Hitler or
Satan himself, she would oppose removing sort
of a strange hill to die on, I must say.
And at this point, I want to get back to the
Hitler statues thing.
Does anybody else think that Marjorie Taylor
Greene has a sort of strange fixation on Nazis,
Hitler and the Holocaust?
Nonexistent mandatory vaccinations are like
the Holocaust, she says, requiring masks on
the House floor at the House of Representatives.
That's like the Holocaust, a Hitler statue.
If someone wanted to remove it, she would
fight against that.
Her reference to Jewish Jewish space lasers
some months back.
There's something odd here, and I don't know
exactly what it is.
Now, let's get to the concept of you don't
want to remove a Hitler statue so that you
can teach your children about World War Two.
Imagine teaching children about World War
two and the Holocaust in class showing a documentary
film.
Maybe you invite one of the increasingly few
surviving Holocaust survivors to the class
to talk to the kids.
And then you have to do a field trip to the
Hitler statue so that the kids can really
learn about it.
Like how does that even pass the sniff test?
How is that even a remotely acceptable argument,
this entire idea that you need a statue to
learn history or that it's even that useful
in helping people learn history?
It's a bizarre idea.
First of all, who learns history from statues?
I can tell you as someone who I went to school,
sometimes parents, my parents would talk about
history.
I would sometimes read books.
I don't think I've learned any history from
a statue.
It's almost like the right doesn't realize
that documentaries exist.
History books exist, teachers exist, the internet
exists.
You can pick up a book and you can learn something.
It's that simple.
And by the same logic, if she's fine with
statues of figures she's supposedly or apparently
hates, she claims to hate Hitler because of
the historical significance.
Would she be OK with a statue of, like, I
don't know, like a Black Lives Matter leader
or something?
Like if the statue doesn't mean you endorse
it.
She should be in favor of it so that we can
learn about it right or something, it's just
all completely incoherent as we've come to
expect from her and the strain.
She seems to have two primary fixations, Alexandria,
Cassio, Cortez.
She seems obsessed with AOC.
I don't know if she's obsessed with AOC because
she's jealous of Aoki's sort of coalition
and the attention that she gets.
I don't know what it is, but she's obsessed
with AOC.
And then between Jewish space lasers and Hitler,
statues and masks are like the Holocaust.
She seems obsessed with Jewish related issues
as well.
Let me know what you think.
We'll have more about these strange just video
after video involving Marjorie Taylor Green
on our Facebook page, which you can find at
Facebook dot com slash David Pakman show.
We will take a break and much more upcoming
today.